[Music]
hi everyone i'm jaya calmly and together
with my colleague Elliot we will be
talking about a multi empathic rainbow
for recommendations as Netflix
so are any people in the room left who
do not have analytic subscription later
okay so as you already know this is the
Netflix homepage the goal of the Netflix
homepage is to provide relevant
unfertilized content to each of its
members this involves helping the
members quickly find what they would
like to watch as soon as possible the
risk is that if we if the members do not
find the content that they would like to
watch they may lose interest and even
cancel the subscription the challenge is
that we have a hundred and seventeen
million plus members across the groom
recommendation systems thus form a whole
component of the Netflix homepage in
fact recommendation systems were valued
to act about the billion dollars by
Australia recently
so the Netflix homepage transistor of an
idea of algorithms refined for various
different objectives and a few examples
of the algorithms are like for example
for top pegs for trending now because
you want new releases search and even
our web personalization so in alpha
personalization we try to present to you
the right image for the right title our
goal in the stock is a recommendation on
the billboard the goal of the billboard
is to recommend a single large single
relevant title to each of its members
and to respond quickly to member
feedback so the figure over here shows
the billboard for daredevil
it's the large banner that you see on
the Netflix homepage so traditional
approaches for recommendations such as
collaborative filtering have been widely
applied and have been very successfully
applied in various industrial settings
so the idea of collaborative filtering
is based upon the wisdom of the crowd it
is well understood and it is widely used
in practice there are a variety of
different algorithms that exist one of
the most popular algorithm is the matrix
factorization based algorithm so even
though these techniques have been widely
successfully applied in various
industrial settings they face several
challenges when applied to a practical
setting for example scars feedback
dynamic catalog which is very true in
our case because the catalog keeps on
changing new titles get added to the
service non-stationary member base the
member base itself is changing and
growing so there is a time sensitivity
aspect to a lot of these practical
problems that these batch traditional
approaches are not meant to handle for
example the content popularity changes
over time the member interests evolve
over time and as a result these
approaches are not designed to respond
quickly to the member feedback
so a lot of the challenges that I
mentioned over your are not just
restricted to the recommendation domain
they can also be seen in various other
domains for example in clinical trials
where you want to decide what medicine
should you give to a patient in case of
network routing when you want to decide
where should your out your packet to in
case of online advertising when you want
to determine what ad he should you show
on the website in case of AI for games
and even in machine learning in the case
of hyper parameter optimization so a new
set of techniques called as multi
embodied techniques which are basically
online learning techniques have become
increasingly popular in these practical
settings because they are more robust in
handling the challenges that we
mentioned earlier so what exactly are
these multi am bandits so the idea of
modeun bandits is actually quite old and
is inspired from the idea of gambling in
a casino so imagine that there's a
gambler who's gambling in a casino there
are multiple slot machines with unknown
reward distribution so there is a
gambler who has got multiple arms and
the goal of the gambler is to maximize
his earnings or to maximize the reward
and so the key question that the gambler
is asking is which machine should he
play in order to maximize the reward not
over your that the slot machines have
got an unknown reward distribution
because if the reward distribution were
known then all the gambler has to do is
to play the slot machine with the
largest expected reward
so let's see how the bandit algorithms
actually work so there is a learner
which interacts with the environment
while selecting an action and the
environment responds back to the learner
by presenting a reward
so the bandit game proceeds as follows
like for each round the learner chooses
an action from a set of available
actions and presents it to the
environment the environment generates a
real-valued reward and presents it back
to the learner the goal of the learner
is to maximize the cumulative reward or
in terms of the bandit literature
minimize the cumulative regret so the
regret is the difference in the reward
when the action was selected by the
learner versus the optimal action that
could have been selected by the learner
in hindsight so at the heart of all
these bandit algorithms is the
exploration versus the acceleration
trade-off the trade-off is as follows
whether you should recommend the optimal
title given the evidence so far that is
exploit or whether you should recommend
other lesser known titles to gather
feedback that is explore so why exactly
do you need this acceleration so
acceleration even though it may sound
that it involves a shorter term
sacrifice is actually a good long term
strategy so exploitation allows us to
gather information to determine what
would be an overall best action so there
could be various strategies for
exploration but I'm the simplest one
would be the knife exploration strategy
in which you just add some noise to your
greedy policy there could be other
strategies for exploration as well for
example one of the other very famous
strategy is optimism in the face of
uncertainty so what this principle is
saying that you would prefer actions
about which you have little information
so in that way you are going to explore
more around that action and as a result
gather more
feedback about that action and as a
result gain more confidence about your
about your prediction for that action
now there could be other ways for
exploration as well for example
probability matching in case of
probability matching you select the
actions with the according to the
probability by which they are the best
so I forgot to mention that optimism in
the face of uncertainty is the heart of
one of the most famous multi-armed
bandit algorithm which is called as the
upper confidence bound algorithm and
probability matching is is the heart of
Thompson sampling based algorithms so
apart from categorizing the different
material bandits according to the way we
are performing exploration there could
be other ways to categorize the multi
embedded techniques for example the
different environments so in case the
environment is stochastic in stationary
that is one category of Madyan bandit
algorithms so in in by stochastic and
stationary I mean that the reward has
generated iid from a fixed unknown
distribution for the action by
stationary I mean that there is no
payoff drift on the other hand are the
adversarial multi embodied techniques
which do not make any assumption about
how the reward is generated and these
are assumed to be a little bit
pessimistic as compared to the
stochastic in stationary based
techniques now we could also classify
the McGee embody techniques depending
upon the different objectives whether we
want to track the cumulative regret or
whether we want to track the best export
the action space now could be like
either continuous or discrete
it could be finite or infinite so coming
back to our problem there could be
several extensions of these multi
unbounded techniques for example
extensions handling dynamic set of arms
extensions handling context so context
is the feature associated with the
action with the user or with the user
shinpai and these bandits are called
contextual bandits and are very widely
used in practice so in this talk we will
focus upon a very knife or multi-armed
bandit strategy which is which we call a
zip slim greedy approach the idea of
epsilen greedy is very simple in is as
follows with a uniform probability if
epsilon you uniformly explore one of the
titles in your candidate pool the
advantage of this very naive exploration
is that it provides unbiased data which
can be then used for training
exploitation in the in the exploitation
phase we select the optimal action with
the probability 1 minus Epsilon so just
highlighting the key aspects of a
framework so our framework can support
different contextual bandit algorithms
even though we talk about Epsilon greedy
it can very well support other
contextual bandit algorithms like
Thompson's sampling UCB etc it's a
closed loop system so like it helps
establish the link between how
recommendations are made and how the
members respond to them
it supports snapshot logging so logging
of facts which is very helpful for
future generation for offline training
and it provides regular updates of
policies which is very important for
online learning algorithms so as to make
the policies as fresh as possible with
that we'll now move on to the system
architecture which will be covered by le
thanks hi I'm Elliott you know yeah talk
about the architecture of the system
that we use to power these multi
unbranded
experiments that we want to run so this
is a very high-level view of what it
means to serve a recommendation at
Netflix so when we need to do this
online when user comes in we generate
the recommendation online at the same
time we log information about why we
made this recommendation and we also
observe and record what the custom the
member does in response to this
recommendation this data is then put
back together
for training and updating our model so
Jaya mentioned
closing the loop of the system so when
we talk about that we are talking about
this red line right so we have basically
the data associated with recommendation
we want to know exactly what that
ultimately leads to in terms of member
activity so we can break down our system
into online and offline components
online we need to apply or exploit
exploit policy log the contextual
information and of course we need to
score and generate our recommendations
offline will do attribution assignment
to piece together the data and also
model training so first step is to apply
our Explorer exploit policy so we need
to generate a candidate pool of titles
this is that pool of titles the total
pool of titles that we can choose from
when we're trying to pick a picker up
generate a recommendation then we
actually select a title from this
candidate pool in our except salon
greedy case we were first flip a coin to
decide if we want to explore or exploit
in the case of Explorer we'll then
randomly sample from our candidate pool
to pick a title in the exploit case we
can apply our model to pick the the most
optimal recommendation while we're doing
this we also need to log quite a bit of
information especially since we have
different types of bandits that we might
be using understanding why we made
certain decisions like why we made
certain recommendations it's very
important so from the on the bandits
side we want to log information about
things like the exploration probability
the candidate pool that was available at
that time and also the selected title
and we also snapshot facts for our
future generation
so facts for us are pretty loosely
defined it's basically any data that we
can use to derive features from and this
is mostly trade off for us in terms of
how much data why we want to store and
process while also enabling as many
features while enabling us to generate
as many features as we can so next we
can do attribution assignment so this is
the process of taking the data that
we've logged the different bits of data
that we've logged and connecting them
together so this connection needs to be
both correct and meaningful so in our
billboard case we would first filter
down to relevant member activities so in
this case we might be interested only in
events or data that's relevant to the
the billboard experience then we
actually join with the explore and
exploit information and we can also
define and construct our sessions so a
session is just some grouping of these
of member activity that makes sense for
for us when defining our rewards and
labels then from these sessions we can
actually define our labels so just to
recap a little bit this is what it looks
like when we construct our homepage so
one of the components of the homepage is
the Billboard so we will generate the
candidate pool of titles apply our model
and to select one this information along
with a lot of other information about
the other rows is used to actually
render the homepage and eventually the
user can play a title from that homepage
on the logging side this is kind of what
we observe so the key relationship we
want to establish is this dark arrows in
the in the top here this basically
connects the data used for generating
the recommendation all the way through
to what the user actually
dc's on his on the device and to his
ultimate response which is in this case
a play of Title II the gray arrows down
here at the bottom show what additional
relationships that we might be
interested in so it's a possible session
ization strategy we might want to apply
so in this case we're in addition to
just the play and the impression that
directly led to the play we are also
interested in the impressions coming
from the rest of the homepage once we
have our labels defined we can generate
our features so we join our labels with
our snapshot at fax this is done through
a Netflix library called DeLorean and
this library allows us to do time travel
and allows us to pick the correct
version of data to be used for those
labels also this library allows us to
use the same feature encoders online and
offline this prevents us from
introducing discrepancies or bugs when
we switch between the online and offline
worlds and we can guarantee that what we
evaluate in each setting is the same
once we have our labels and features so
we can finally train them validate our
model and when that looks good we can
publish the model to production so the
model is running and we want to make
sure that things are looking what good
aside from just normal AP test metrics
for these multi-armed bandit models we
found a few other kind of classes of
metrics to be useful to look at first is
about the distribution of the arm poles
so you have many many arms that you
potentially are selecting from so you
want to make sure that when you observe
what your model is doing that it's
fairly stable otherwise you it might be
misbehaving you also want to look
and compare explore and exploit we did
look at the differences between explore
and exploit since explore especially if
you're doing uniform exploration the
distribution should be fairly well
uniformly distributed over all the arms
and your exploit should hopefully be
picking better titles over less popular
titles we also want to look at take
great related metrics so hopefully our
model is learning and improving so they
should be converging over time and
relatively quickly we also want to
compare online and offline results of
take our take rate estimates so that we
know that there are at least
directionally observing the same things
and we also again want to compare
explore and exploit so so especially
since explore is random we would hope
that our recommendations and exploit are
better than random and with that I'll
let Jaya tell you more about some of the
experiments that we've actually tried
with this system
so so far we have seen the framework for
so far we have seen the framework for
generation of these multi embodied
policies so let's now look at like some
of the example policies that we
implemented using this framework so
before we go on to the framework let's
have a quick look at the notation let
small K denote the set of titles that
are there in the candidate pool when a
member arrives on the Netflix homepage
let X I key denote the context vector
context vector for the member I and the
title K so the context vector could
represent the features for the member
the features for the title the features
for the member title pair and also
features for the session and so on let
why I carry present' the label when the
member I was shown the title K so the
very first policy that we consider is a
simple policy which we call as the
greedy exploit policy the policy is as
follows we learn a model for title in
the candidate pool to predict the
likelihood of play and finally we select
a winning title which maximizes this
probability of play so now various
models could be used to predict the
probability of play for example logistic
regression neural net networks or
gradient boosted decision trees so just
to give a recap the member arrives on
the Netflix homepage we have four titles
in the candidate pool we extract the
features for the member and the title we
already have generated four models we
have already trained four models earlier
so what we do is now online time we just
score the four models for the member for
the features that we extracted and
compute a probability of play finally we
select a winning title as a title which
maximizes our probability of play
so very simple but oftentimes a key
question that we ask in recommendation
is whether the member played the title
because we showed it to them or would
they have played the title anyways so
this key question is very important and
has been studied in various other
domains as well for example let's
consider the case of search advertising
the goal of search advertising is to
target users to increase the conversion
so over here we see that when a user
comes on the Google website he types the
keyword Macy's so the top link is the
link is the sponsored link to the Macy's
website and the bottom link is the
actual link to the Macy's website so
when the user has typed the keyword
Macy's they have already actually
expressed their intent to buy so when
finally they convert the key question to
ask is whether they converted because
the ad was shown to them or would they
have converted anyways so this brings us
to a very important concept called as
incrementality which is widely used in
advertising the goal of incremental 'ti
is to measure ad effectiveness so how
incremental t proceeds is as follows you
randomly divide your population in two
control and treatment group in your
control group you show other people's
advertisement and in the treatment group
you show your own advertisement and
finally you compute the difference in
the revenue generated from the
advertisement and compute this Delta
which is known as the incremental lift
or the incremental value of the
advertisement so incrementality actually
helps measure the difference in the
outcome because the ad was shown and
because the ad was not shown so let's
try to map this concept of
incrementality into our case which is
the billboard case so what we want to do
if we want to have an incremental policy
on the billboard we want to show the
title which has the largest additional
benefit from being shown on the before
note that apart from the billboard there
are the rest of the home page is Welkin
surface the title so the member could
see the title because the other rows
showed the title or also because he
searched the title so popular titles
tend to appear multiple times on the
Netflix home page for example trending
now so in this case it might be better
to utilize the real estate on the
Netflix homepage by showing a title
which would have the largest additional
benefit from from being shown on the
Billboard so we can define now an
incremental policy on the billboard by
saying that a policy which is
incremental with respect to the
probability of play so just summarizing
it the goal of an incremental policy on
a billboard is to recommend the title
which has the largest additional benefit
from being shown on the billboard so now
instead of a greedy exploit policy in
which we were trying to maximize the
probability of play what we do is try to
maximize the Delta probability of play
where the Delta is computed as the
difference in the probability of play
when the title was shown on the
billboard versus when the title was not
shown on the billboard so we have these
two policies right now the exploit
policy and the incremental incremental
ad based policy what we did was we did a
offline and online comparison of these
two policies so for offline comparison
we relied upon this method called replay
which is a standard method for
evaluating contextual bandit algorithms
so the method is as follows
it relies upon uniform acceleration data
and it assumes that for every record in
the expression data we already know the
title which was shown the context vector
the reward which was obtained and the
list of the candidate titles so the
method proceeds as follows for every
record in the acceleration data we
evaluate the Train model on all of the
lists of the candidate
so the candidate titles are the titles
that could have been shown instead of
this title which was shown in the
expression data we picked the winning
title according to the Train model let
the winning title be K - and finally we
construct a history in which we can keep
a record in the history only if the
winning title K - equals to the title
which was shown in the exploration log
data and finally we compute the metrics
from this history so just revising it
again like we have for every record in
the acceleration data we have the
context the title which was shown the
reward that was obtained and the list of
the candidate titles for every candidate
title we reveal the context to the Train
model the Train model selects a winning
title k - we use the reward or like we
append to the history only if the reward
only if the winning title K - is equal
to the title K which was logged in the
acceleration data and at the end of it
we compute the metric which is like in
this case let's say T crate by just
computing the number of plays divided by
the number of matches from the history
so the figure over here shows an offline
lift in replay as compared to the random
baseline for the two policies the
exploit policy and the incrementality
based policy so as we see over your the
exploit based policy performs a little
bit better than incrementality based
policy and this is kind of a little bit
expected as well because the exploit
policy is going to optimize for the for
the most popular title or the title
which has the highest probability of
play and the incrementality based policy
kind of sacrifices that by showing a
lesser-known title which would benefit
by being shown on the billboard so let's
take a deeper look at this and try to
understand this part a little bit better
like which titles would actually benefit
from being shown on the Billboard so the
figure over your shows a scatterplot
between the baseline probability of play
and the incremental probability of play
so over your we see that title a
represented by the blue dots has got a
very low baseline probability of play
but as when you show it on the billboard
its incremental probability of play is
very high which means that this title
would definitely benefit by being shown
on the billboard on the other hand is
titled C which is represented by the
green dots which already has a very high
baseline baseline probability of play so
it's probably a very popular title so
because of that it doesn't benefit as
much by being shown on the billboard and
hence its incremental probability of
play is not that high so definitely
title C doesn't benefit from being shown
on the billboard whereas title a does
benefit from being shown on the
billboard
we also did an online comparison of the
ds2 policies and what we saw online was
that the replay tickets definitely
follow the patterns that we had seen
offline and our implementation of
incrementality the way we defined that
over here is able to shift the
engagement within the candidate pool
from a very popular title to some of the
lesser-known titles in the candidate
pool so so far we have seen that we
provided a general framework for
recommendation of multi embarrassed
algorithms we can plug in different
multi unbonded policies we showed an
example of two simple policies but the
framework is very generic and allows it
enables research in various directions
for example research in the direction of
policy exploration now we can plug in
different multi-armed bandit policies
for example Thompson sampling UCB etc
they could be other ways of combining
causal inference of causal inference is
really important in trying to understand
the value of recommendation and we just
presented a very simple way increment of
incrementality based policy to plug in
causal influence but maybe there are
like other different ways which we can
try to explore using this framework we
can also do Alec model explanation for
example plug in different models neural
networks loss stick regression abilities
etc another key thing that the framework
allows which is very important is reward
expression so so far we have shown like
probably a short term reward in which we
are trying to optimize for let's say the
probability of play or something like
that but as a company we generally care
about like long term reward like
retention for example and hence how can
we bring in those long term rewards
that's definitely an area of research as
well maybe it involves moving more
towards reinforcement learning but yes
the framework opens the door for like
exploring
the different kinds of robots as well
also the they could be different kinds
of rewards which could be obtained from
from different things for example play
versus play from the billboard versus
like let's say something else so the
framework allows us to explore these
different kinds of rewards as well thank
you
so with that we have excellent so we've
got time for two questions and then
reminder again
jaian Elliott will both be in office
hours just out the store to the left
after this so let's take two questions
now question number one hi that was a
great talk thank you very much
highlighting the differences between the
greedy exploit and the incrementality
based one so clearly there's like a tray
our trade-off between like showing the
title that has just straight up the
greatest probability of play but then
also you know how do you get more
attention to the ones that are
lesser-known that would give an increase
in place so I'm sorry if you already
went over it but how does that decision
get made between the two is is there a
specific thing you guys do to choose
between the one that is the highest or
the highest increase oh so these are two
different policies like the baby I've
shown over here they are completely
different policies so they don't
interact with each other and like we
studied the two policies in isolation
but that's a very good question like
maybe we can try to like bridge the gap
and blend the two together and like have
another policy which I guess maybe an
instable of the two did you know what
happens with doing that okay cool thank
you
[Laughter]
microphone no microphone no no question
[Laughter]
for us all right
hi there kind of as a Netflix consumer
I'm just kind of interested what do you
regard as a successful play because if I
am induced to click something and I
watch 25 minutes of the opening episode
of a season and I don't like it
I actually that's that's negative to me
because you've wasted 25 minutes of my
time
so do you regard that as a success or a
failure actually there are no specific
rules of thumbs like we have like a
variety of different algorithms which
are defined for like a completely
different objectives and yeah
there is no slick specific rule on like
we should define a play as this or that
[Music]